et on reçoit notre invité du vendredi
bonsoir bonjour à vous merci de votre
accueil alors claudine salomon moto vous
êtes la présidente des fêtes de thalys
est une association et vous organisez
plein de choses mais notamment deux
concerts samedi 3 et dimanche 4 le
premier concert à thoiry samedi 3 et
dimanche 4 à vic alors d'abord votre
association qui a été créée en 99 les
fêtes de thalie vous êtes là pour
promouvoir la musique baroque voilà j'ai
créé en fait un ensemble musical qui
était au départ tout à fait amateur nous
étions quatre musiciennes et nous avons
pensé que pour faire quelque chose il
fallait se donner un nom il fallait
avoir une association d'une structure et
comme notre idée c'était de faire des
choses dans des occasions festives on a
cherché un nom qui illustre un petit peu
c'est fait et on a trouvé le alors on a
trouvé le nom de défaite de talent n'a
requis
alors thalys est la muse de la comédie
les fêtes de thalie c'est en fait le nom
d'un opéra baroque de jean-joseph mouret
compositeur du 18e siècle qui a créé des
décompositions autour des pièces de
marivaux en particulier qui est pas très
connu et cette oeuvre donc c'est un un
opéra ballet et dans lequel nous avons
trouvé dix ont l'idée de fête que nous
cherchions puisque la muse de la comédie
repousse la muse de la tragédie en
disant pousse toi de là que je m'y
mettre c'est beaucoup plus drôle ce que
je fais enfin
alors la musique parce que c'est la
musique qui est drôle dans tout l'est
cette musique qui peut paraître un peu
abstrait pour certains qu'est ce qui
vous a intéressé dans cette musique en
particulier alors on aime aussi à
laroque est beaucoup plus drôle qu'on ne
croit beaucoup la musique proche et
voilà beaucoup plus proche de nous qu'on
ne croit en fait je personnellement je
suis venu à la musique baroque parce que
j'avais envie de faire du jazz vous
allez me dire quel rapport entre le jazz
et la musique baroque un bruit de fond
alors je vous ai coupé je voulais juste
qu'on en entende bien ce que
donc en fait la musique baroque c'est
une partie de la musique classique
qui couvre la moitié du xviie et la
moitié du xviiie siècle en fait à cheval
sur le xviie et xviiie siècles qui
correspond en littérature à la
classicisme
mais ce classicisme de la littérature
comme de la musique comme de la peinture
comme du larchitecture c'est un cadre
assez rigide à l'intérieur duquel il ya
une quantité de fioritures incroyable ah
bon je vous ai coupé parce que je
voulais qu'on va entendre cette musique
vous expliquer qu'au départ vous n'étiez
pas
directement branché
on arrive
parce que je suis tombé sur un
professeur qui par commodité pour me
faire débuter la flûte m'a mis entre les
mains des oeuvres baroques parce que
sont les plus simples pour commencer
elle même ne se connaissaient pas en
jazz donc c'était pour démarrer la flûte
et
je suis ensuite allé dans un stage de
musique pour accélérer mon apprentissage
puisque j'ai commencé en étant adulte la
flûte et dans ce stage est découvert une
approche de la musique baroque qui était
naissante à l'époque puisqu'il ya quand
même eu un très grand renouveau dans
l'interprétation de cette musique a été
redécouverte
disons il ya trente 30 40 ans maintenant
bon pour citer des ensembles très connu
il ya l'ensemble de gustav leonhardt
consomme de nikolaus harnoncourt qui ont
fait énormément il ya une évolution au
sein même de voilà dans le dans la
proche la proche de cette musique en
utilisant des instruments anciens
en replongeant un peu dans les traités
pour comprendre l'état d'esprit des
des musiciens de l'époque et il y a une
très grande analogie avec le jazz dans
la mesure où beaucoup de cette musique
n'est pas complètement écrite c'est à
dire que il ya par exemple la basse qui
est la fondamentale de la musique qui
est écrite avec des chiffrages ce ne
sont pas les mêmes qu'en jazz mais qui
ressemble beaucoup et à l'intérieur de
ça le musicien a une grande liberté
d'interprétation donc à savoir qu'on
peut faire des boeufs en musique
les parties de dessus donc les parties
les mélodies si vous voulez sont écrites
souvent de façon très épuré et laisse à
l'interprète la possibilité d'ajouter
des ornements qui sont en fait comme
l'improvisation jazz alors c'est codifié
c'est
grandes différences selon les
compositeurs ce soit ma française
italienne allemande et c'est
beaucoup de courant mais dans l'ensemble
c'est une musique qui laisse une grande
liberté et dont la lecture musicale au
plan technique est plus proche de la
lecture du jazz que de la lecture du
classique c'est incroyable sur ses
jambes quand même en train de découvrir
des choses avec vous là c'est un goût
alors ce concert il ya deux concerts un
samedi 3 et dimanche 4 novembre j'ai dit
samedi 3 au soir à à thoiry au château
de thoiry dans la soirée où je précise
malheureusement pour ceux qui pourraient
rêver le magnifique lac sein du château
de thoiry ne peut pas être utilisé voilà
bon agréable comme un concert et puis un
concert le dimanche 4 novembre au musée
de vic alors
qu'elles sont quel est le programme de
ces deux concerts est ce que c'est de la
classique baroque ou est-ce que c'est du
baroque revisiter ses du baroque tel
qu'on le joue aujourd'hui sur les
instruments anciens c'est à dire
un peu dépoussiéré par rapport à ce
qu'on faisait là ses compositions les
plus connus alors les plus connus bien
gentil bastien bac
vivaldi
rameau couperin
que dire encore
bon pour citer ceux qui sont qui sont là
au programme en fait on tourne autour de
cela d'ailleurs parce qu'on a orienté le
programme sur le tricentenaire de la
naissance de jean jacques rousseau qui
n'est pas quelqu'un forcément très drôle
mais qui a fait de la musique qui a qui
s'est distingué dans une querelle à
l'époque entre la musique française et
la musique italienne et puis un autre
compositeur qui n'étaient pas connus
comme compositeur par le grand public
c'est le roi de prusse qui était
musicien amateur et qui a joué de la
flûte et qui a composé aussi donc
notre flûtiste a eu envie de mettre à
l'honneur
ceux frédéric de frédéric 2 frédéric le
grand roi de prusse dans une de ses
oeuvres et puis je vais trouver une
oeuvre de jean jacques rousseau en fait
c'est un arrangement que jean jacques
rousseau a fait d'un concerto très connu
de vivaldi et le printemps qu'il a
arrangé pour flûte seule
sinon il a fait d'autres compositions
qui ne sont pas notre guerre qu'on
voulait pour le chant samedi 3 novembre
à 21 heures au château de thoiry et puis
dimanche 4 novembre à 16 heures au musée
de devic alors votre association
réaliser concernent organise également
des stages mais alors il faut être super
fort en bas du dos rond et on est mieux
pas quoi mais avec musiciens des ions
départ oui bon musicien parce que sinon
ce serait frustrant
mais ce sont des stages alors les
concerts sont organisés à l'opposé à
l'occasion du stage en fait qu'on ce
stage pour des gens qui sont déjà un peu
musicien ou beaucoup musiciens il ya
tous les niveaux qui se mélangent
mais s'est orienté sur la pratique de
l'instrument des instruments par an
c'est sur la flûte ou à d'autres
instruments flûtes eu viol
violoncelle violon baroque clavecin donc
par exemple quelqu'un qui joue du piano
qui voudraient s'initier au clavecin et
peut venir
quelqu'un qui joue de la flûte moderne
et qui voudraient découvrir la flûte
baroque qui est quand même très
différentes ils peuvent dire aussi nous
voir il ensuite il ne repart plus
nous avons un stage par exemple un
monsieur qui est venue il ya quelques
années la première année il est venu
journée la deuxième année il est venue
deux jours la troisième trois jours et
maintenant il vient une semaine et vient
à tous les stages parce qu'ils avaient
voté dix bornes à la musique va en voilà
et puissent puis l'enseignement de faim
l'atmosphère du sage lui a plu et c'est
assez peu conventionnelle est très
familiale pour moi c'est un seul agent
lieu au mois d'avril alors le prochain
v1 nada 25 avril au 5 mai donc là on en
allant dans tout et sur internet
vous avez fait de thalie point org merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur notre plateau
pour nous parler de cette musique si
particulière je pense qu'on a beaucoup
appris de choses avec vous aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs c'est si vous voulez en
savoir plus n'hésitez pas à aller sur le
site et puis à recevoir les nouvelles
voilà et surtout à venir au concert et
pas voilà le les concerne le site tous
est inscrit sur l'écran céder aux
téléspectateurs veulent se renseigner
merci beaucoup à vous